hello I'm Greg Sadler I'm a big fan of
speculative fiction since childhood I'm
also a practicing philosopher and I'd
like to tell you about a series that
I've got that brings the two of those
together
intersecting it's been going on for
quite a long time and we've got dozens
of session videos that you can check out
it's called worlds of speculative
fiction and the focus is indeed on
narrative worlds or narrative universes
I'll talk about that in a moment but
another key component of it is that we
delve into selected philosophical themes
so in a way you're getting the Best of
Both Worlds analysis of some really fun
interesting meaty literature and some
philosophical depth and rigor brought to
it as well so if you don't know about
the C series it started in 2016 it was
originally held as an in-person
face-to-face event and we went on like
that all the way up to the beginning of
the covid lockdown so it was hosted at
the Brookfield Public Library it was a
monthly series actually it still is a
monthly series and in each of them
except for the very first one where
we're talking about sort of generalities
what is fantasy what is science fiction
what is speculative fiction we would
take an author and a series of texts in
which there's a shared narrative
universe so for example in the first
year we did George RR Martin's Game of
Thrones uh you know AKA Song of Ice and
Fire the five books that we had at that
time available and still have available
we did J.R tolkien's Lord of the Rings
Hobbit and Summerlin together we did
Frank Herbert's Dune series we did uh
Ursula K the Queen's heinish novels we
can go on and on and on those are just
some examples in every one of them
there's a world to explore a universe
and that's usually tied in with some key
philosophical ideas so we did it for 12
sessions for a year and then we got
invited back to do it for another year
and another year at another year and
then we hit covid and then we had to
take a break and rethink what we were
going to do and since then the series
has taken on a different shape although
not different intention and content so
what we do now is it's an online event
that you can join in on wherever you
happen to be in the world and what we do
is we have a roughly 90 minute video
premiere in which I'm talking presenting
going over some of the World building
some of the philosophical themes
sometimes biography of the author if we
haven't hit on that yet sometimes what
the author him or herself has to say
about the world and the characters and
the themes that they're working with so
we do that for 90 minutes or sometimes a
little bit longer quite admittedly and
we do that with live chat so people can
say whatever they want in the comments
and I answer them in there and then
afterwards we shift to video
conferencing with zoom so that we can
continue the conversation and it's it's
a lot of fun we haven't gotten back to
face to face although we're looking into
maybe doing that again partnering with
the Brookfield Library perhaps not every
session but maybe you know once a
quarter or so but for the time being
that that's the configuration you can
find the videos for all of these in
several different places there's a page
and medium that has all of them linked
to there's obviously a YouTube playlist
since these are YouTube videos and
there's also a free online course that
you can sign up for it's in the video
description below just click on the link
it'll take you there then you can get
news about all of this stuff and so I
there's a few other things I do want to
say before of course inviting you to
join in whatever sessions you'd like to
so one is how do I pick these out well
you know the first year I just picked
writers that I knew that I liked and
wanted to go back to it was kind of
guilty pleasure reading and then I did
the same thing the second year but since
then because you know we're now getting
close to doing this we'll we'll have
done it for a decade in 2026.
I've been to soliciting input from the
people involved in the sessions and then
much more widely so around December
every year you're going to see me in my
social media and in in my videos putting
out two different calls the first one is
give me your suggestions for any author
and series that we haven't already
covered now you do want to take a look
at who we've actually done because we've
done quite a few we're pushing 70
sessions at this point so we've already
hit on quite a few we could always go
back and look at you know some series
and greater depth and detail later on
down the line but I looked for the
suggestions and the ones that get some
real traction because I usually get
anywhere from like 30 to 60 different
suggestions I look for which ones are
being suggested more than once and then
we take the top six
and we do a vote and everybody gets to
vote if they want to
um I put it out in all my different
social media you vote on who you
actually want to see and I reserve three
slots out of 12 each year for these fan
favorites right and this is a great way
that I get introduced to writers that I
wouldn't myself have come across before
you know all sorts of interesting series
that I just haven't had the time for and
so I follow these out and they're almost
always great suggestions you can
actually see some of them over here Kim
Stanley Robinson Mars uh you know Dan
Simmons Hyperion cantos you know our
Scott backers Prince of nothing Trilogy
we can go on and on and on so the last
thing that I should mention too is
what's the scope of the series as I
mentioned we're looking at philosophical
themes we're looking how you know plot
character setting come together in a
narrative universe and exploring that
we're also looking at what the author's
intentions are but what is speculative
fiction so speculative fiction you know
includes fantasy and science fiction and
everything in between like science
fantasy and all the different kinds of
Science Fiction it also includes horror
and that means that there's also an
overlap with what we call weird Tales
which sometimes Go in different
directions it also includes uh you know
dystopian and utopian literature it
includes alternate history it includes
superhero stuff it includes a whole
bunch of different interesting stuff
including even nonsense stuff like Lewis
Carroll's Alice in Wonderland so there's
a vast variety of authors the main thing
for this series is that we're always
interested in is finding a narrative
universe that typically will span
multiple stories or multiple novels
because that makes for a really fun
enjoyable
interesting engaging exploration so I
hope that you can join me for some of
these great sessions coming up we're
going to be continuing this for many
years to come I imagine because there's
lots and lots of authors for me to
explore many for you to suggest all of
us to enjoy and you can look back at the
many many videos that we already have if
if you want to see what I happen to
think about you know Mervin Peaks Gorman
ghast or any other author and series
that we've already covered you can see
me sometimes discussing it with others
sometimes just presenting on my own but
it's all a way of kind of geeking out
together and engaging in some fun
interesting philosophically Rich reading
so I hope that you'll join me whether
looking at older videos or whether
joining in on sessions you have to come
and perhaps even joining in on the
suggestions and the votes come every
December so I'll see you in the series